♪
>> Dagen: WELCOME BACK, TIME
FOR "THE FASTEST," BRADLEY
COOPER IS REPORTEDLY DATING
HUMA ABEDIN, THE TOP CONFIDENT
TRADING HER HUSBAND
ANTHONY WEINER FOR IN A LISTER.
GREG, WHO DEAR AT THE TWO TREAD
WHERE THE DASHED OFF THE TREAD?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY
ARE DOING THIS, BUT IT DOES NOT
EVEN MAKE SENSE TO ME.
>> Jesse: WHY DOES IT NOT MAKE
SENSE?
>> Greg: BECAUSE
ANTHONY WEINER WAS SUCH A PRIZE
IN A MOVE ON TO TRASH LIKE
BRADLEY COOPER, LET'S BE HONEST,
GOING DOWNHILL.
>> Dagen: AND ANNA WHITMORE
WAS THE MATCHMAKER, I'M SURE
THAT THIS IS FOREVER.
>> Martha: I LOVE THE ROMANTIC
STATEMENT FROM THE SOURCE, THEY
ARE PERFECT FOR EACH OTHER, BOTH
INTO POWER, POLITICS, AND HUMAN
AFFAIRS.
ISN'T THAT WHAT YOU SAY WHEN TWO
GREAT PEOPLE THAT YOU LOVE FALL
FOR EACH OTHER?
>> Greg: ANONYMOUS GOSSIP
QUOTES, LEADING LIKE A HUMAN
BEING.
>> Jessica: LEADING WITH
POWER.
AND PROBABLY PART OF THE WHOLE
THING.
THAT'S WHAT IT WILL TURN OUT TO
BE.
I WAS SURPRISED BY IT THOUGH.
THAT IT WAS EVEN A FAKE,
POTENTIALLY AFFECTING.
>> Jesse: I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT YOU.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS REAL AND NOW
YOU GUYS ARE MAKING ME FEEL --
>> Jessica: NAIVE?
>> Jesse: NAIVE.
LISTEN, I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE IS
DOING.
>> Greg: GET ANTHONY ON YOUR
SHOW TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
>> Jesse: SHOULD I HAVE THEM
ON THE SHOW?
>> Greg: I TRIED, HE SAID NO
TO ME.
>> Martha: TRY AGAIN.
>> Jesse: WEINER IF YOU ARE
WATCHING?
>> Martha: HE IS THE BIGGEST
JACKASS ON EARTH.
A STONE COLD --
>> Greg: HE USED TO COME ON
FOX ALL THE TIME.
>> Dagen: BECAUSE HE USED TO
BE A LITTLE AND TALK DOWN TO THE
PEOPLE IN OUR GREENROOM, AND
THERE IS NO LOWER LOW THAN THAT.
>> Greg: TO BE FAIR, THOSE
PEOPLE ARE JOKES.
I AM BEING DEA